so you mentioned the human condition
speaking which
you happen to be a human being who is
unfortunately
not immortal
that seems to be a fundamental part of
the human condition that this riot ends
do you think about
the fact that you're going to die one
day are you afraid of death
i i would say that i am
not as much afraid of death as i am of
um degeneration
uh and uh i say that
in part for
reasons of having
you know
seen some tragic degenerative situations
unfold
it's exciting
when
you can
continue to
participate and uh
feel like you're you're near the
the place where the
the wave is breaking on the shore i feel
like you know
um and
and i
i i think about
you know my own uh future potential
um if if i were to undergo a
begin to suffer from dementia uh
alzheimer's disease or semantic dementia
or some other condition
you know
i would sort of gradually lose the
thread of that ability and um
uh so so
one can live on for several
for a decade after you know
sort of having to retire because one no
longer has
uh these kinds of um abilities to engage
and uh i think that's the thing that i
feared the most the losing of that like
the that that um
the breaking of the way the flourishing
of the mind where you could have these
ideas and they're swimming around you're
able to play with them yeah and and and
and collaborate with other people who
you know are themselves uh
um really helping to push these ideas
forward so
yeah what about the edge of the cliff
the end i mean the the mystery of it the
i mean
the migrated
sort of conception of mind and
you know sort of continuous sort of way
of thinking about most things makes it
so that
uh to to me the the the um
the discreteness of that transition is
less
less less less apparent than it seems to
be to most people i see
i see yeah
um
yeah i wonder so i don't know if you
know the work of ernest becker and so on
i wonder what what role mortality
and our ability to be cognizant of it
and anticipate it and perhaps be afraid
of it what role that plays in in our
reasoning of the world
i think that it it can be motivating to
people to think they have a limited
period left um
i think in in my own case you know it
it's like seven or eight years ago now
that i was
i was sitting around doing experiments
on decision making that were
satisfying in a certain way because i
could really
get closure on what
whether the model fit the data perfectly
or not and i could see how one could
test you know the predictions in monkeys
as well as humans and really see what
the neurons were doing
but i just
realized hey wait a minute you know i
may only have about 10 or 15 years left
here
and
i don't feel like i'm getting towards
the answers to the really interesting
questions while i'm doing this
this particular level of work and that's
when i said to myself
okay um let's pick something
that's hard
yeah you know so that's when i started
working on mathematical cognition
and um
i i think it was more in terms of well i
got 15 more years possibly of useful
life left let's imagine that it's only
10.
i'm actually getting close to the end of
that now maybe three or four more years
um but i'm beginning to feel like well i
probably have another five after that so
okay i'll give myself another another
six or eight
um but a deadline is limited and they're
not going to go on forever yeah and so
um
so uh yeah i got to keep um thinking
about the questions that i think are the
interesting and important ones for sure
you